hoy llamará castro quien se posiciona
como primera presidenta de honduras se
recibe un país con casi 10 millones de
habitantes en situación de pobreza 4 de
cada 10 ciudadanos carecen de los
recursos para adquirir un plato de
comida al día en un contexto de
corrupción narcotráfico y de violencia
que se evidencia en casi 40 homicidios
por cada 100.000 personas
castró de 62 años es la esposa del
derrocado mandatario manuel zelaya y
quien regreso de la vida del partido
libre la sucesora del actual presidente
de juan orlando hernández se llega con
el objetivo de reinstaurar la ley contra
la impunidad dada de baja por el
gobierno anterior envuelto además en
corrupción
el hermano del anterior mandatario jimmy
hernández es acusado en eeuu por
narcotráfico
esta presidencia que inicia es el tema
de análisis con nuestra segunda invitado
del día de jessica sánchez ella es
analista representante y directora del
grupo sociedad civil de honduras
jessica gracias a usted y todavía no
empieza en el cargo xiomara y ya se
enfrenta a la primera crisis de su
gobierno con una doble junta directiva
en el congreso castro ya le ofreció al
diputado en rebelión jorge cálix que
asumió la dirección paralela del
congreso con cerca de 20 del legislador
es que sea su jefe de gabinete usted
como cree que puede resolverse esta puja
creo que gracias a ustedes por recibirme
a hoy
se puede negociar todavía bueno tal vez
no se anuncia la palabra pero se puede
todavía llegar a un acuerdo o un
consenso para que se establezca una sola
junta directiva en el congreso y aparte
de eso pues aquí en el ambiente hay
mucha alegría sobre todo porque es una
mujer la mandataria soy yo que habíamos
acariciado desde hace mucho tiempo y que
justo cae en los días de la celebración
del 25 de enero el día de la mujer
hondureña
y donde se por primera vez los derechos
civiles y políticos son otorgados a las
mujeres pero nosotros creemos que ese es
uno de los temas que pueden
llegar a acuerdos mediante el diálogo de
lo contrario pues estaría siendo es muy
difícil la relación entre el ejecutivo y
el legislativo
jessica hablando de este tema que
concuerda con la celebración del día de
la mujer podemos esperar de este
gobierno que haya avances en los
derechos de las mujeres cuál es la
expectativa de las de colectivas
feministas porque una presidenta mujer
no necesariamente es sinónimo de
feminismo
exactamente bueno el partido libre se
denominó se autodenominó feminista y la
propuesta de berta cáceres casi desde su
inicio casi desde su conformación la
presidenta se ha autodenominado también
feminista y ha recibido la agenda de las
mujeres que entre los puntos principales
viene la despenalización de las píldoras
de anticoncepción de emergencia que
recordarán estas fueron prohibidas
durante el golpe de estado
los temas de violencia contra la mujer y
los temas de reactivación económica y
presupuesto entonces nosotros estamos
esperando ahí otro punto muy importante
las casas refugios de violencia contra
la mujer que ahora
son privadas no tenemos un aparato
público de
protección de violencia contra la mujer
y otro tema que creemos que es muy
importante es junto a la reactivación
económica es el tema de las mujeres
migrantes porque honduras ha sido un
país muy conservador en términos de
inmigración pero desde hace algún tiempo
con la primera caravana migrante
honduras empieza a expulsar mucha
cantidad de gente y mucho más mujeres
más o menos un 55 por ciento entonces
creemos que si ella se ha comprometido
con esta agenda de las mujeres falta que
ver si en realidad como tú dices pueden
ser feministas de inicio si se
compromete a la gente tendrá muchísimo
que demostrar en este periodo y tenemos
que hacer una clara diferencia entre lo
que es la candidata y lo que es la
presidenta que ya tiene el deber de
cumplir todas esas promesas que hizo
pero vamos a seguir por la línea de la
migración que en efecto afecta muchísimo
a las mujeres especialmente mujeres
cabezas de familia que representa en ese
sentido la visita de la vicepresidenta
de los eeuu kamala harris a esta
posición presidencial siendo harris
precisamente la abanderada de los temas
de migraciones del gobierno yo hayden
muchas de esas migraciones que se
producen desde centroamérica
creemos que es un espaldarazo yo creo
que es un espaldarazo al gobierno de
xiomara
para hacer acuerdos que revitalicen los
espacios económicos sobre todo para las
mujeres y sus familias también para los
hombres pero básicamente para las
mujeres eso tiene que ver con reducir
los los niveles de violencia que sufren
las mujeres porque como tú decías aquí
el porcentaje asesinatos en suma es
bastante fuerte pero también el de
femicidios honduras está dentro de la
iniciativa es out light porque es uno de
los países que importan por
promedio tiene dos a tres muertes de
mujeres por día femicidios y justamente
ayer hubieron dos de forma bastante
brutal entonces se tiene también que a
la parte de la reactivación económica
ver la estrategia de seguridad de
centroamérica y cómo se va a manejar
todo este tema de el control del crimen
organizado y la seguridad misma en la
población
bueno y jessica uno de los temas bandera
de xiomara en este gobierno es la ley
anti impunidad que quiere reinstaurar en
el país y que salió bajo el mandato de
juan orlando hernández hoy con su
hermano vinculado por acusaciones de
narcotráfico
decía xiomara castró que los que llamó
traidores del congreso estos diputados
que decidieron hacer una junta directiva
paralela lo que hacen es apoyar la
impunidad por aliarse con los seguidores
de hernández usted ve posible cómo
inicia este gobierno con las primeras
muestras que nos da que ella sí logre
reinstaurar esta ley anti impunidad
creemos que sí y se está viendo desde el
primer día o sea de su mandato que soy
la instalación no de la misión de la
corrupción impunidad porque les fue de
más de carácter un poco más cerrado con
poca intervención internacional y cuya
ejecución de la ley estaba en manos de
los nacionales o sea no no podían haber
sentencias internacionales entonces lo
que lo que se quiere es una coalición
una comisión contra la impunidad de
carácter internacional no porque son
también delitos como el narcotráfico el
lavado de activos que tienen que ver con
redes internacionales entonces esa es la
expiración de la población y en medio de
esta digamos sí sí
con hache al final se implantaría a la
ley contra la impunidad que recogerían
todos los casos de corrupción que hemos
visto desde el caso del seguro social
hasta hace poco el caso de los
hospitales móviles fueron como 500
millones en unos hospitales móviles que
supuestamente iban a venir y que nunca
llegaron o sea que no tenemos en él se
trabajó durante la pandemia con los
mismos hospitales que ya habían
rebasados entonces esa es una de las
principales demandas de la población
esta instalación y elevación de la ley
de secretos porque esa era otro tema
ligado a la impunidad entonces uno no
podía investigar ni se podían hacer
investigaciones de carácter público
porque la ley de secreto lo impedía y ya
para el cierre es jessica le quisiera
hablar de este regreso de la izquierda a
honduras usted cree que esto permitirá
que se abra el espectro político o cree
que puede ser una oportunidad para que
crezca por el contrario la polarización
yo creo que puede ser pueden ser las dos
porque no se sabe hacia dónde
va digamos direccionarse el panorama
centroamericano sin embargo la presencia
de kamala harris y de personajes fuertes
de los eeuu y de todo el mundo
más bien indica que esta va a ser una
agenda en desarrollo
el gobierno socialdemócrata como lo
mencioné xiomara donde las prioridades
del pueblo van a estar primero venimos
de 12 años de un golpe de estado donde
los conservadores han echado raíces en
todos los poderes del estado y en los
contratos estatales entonces xiomara
tiene mucha demanda mucha demanda por
ser mujeres de 10 saben que las mujeres
siempre se nos exige toda la lista de
navidad' que lo hagamos que lo hagamos
bien
pero también es el tema de que se está
exigiendo mucho de inicio porque este
país está quebrado
bien lo decía este país está
enfrentándose a un nivel de violencia
que ha sido instalado durante todos
estos 12 años entonces xiomara tiene un
doble red no sólo cumplir la agenda del
pueblo sino desinstalar
y proyectos programas y armados que como
le digo tienen raíces como el proyecto
de las sedes o las zonas industriales de
desarrollo y que ya es un decreto y que
se iba a hacer o sea hay cosas muy
fuertes con las que semana tiene que
luchar y dentro de ellas están eso es
eso creo que es la gran conclusión y
también veremos como lo hace una mujer
porque de parte de la izquierda no anna
vicios siempre han sido su mayoría una
oportunidad en fin para que se llamará
demuestre de qué está hecha y qué puede
hacer con el gobierno jessica sánchez
analista y directora del grupo sociedad
civil de honduras gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros
muchísimas gracias a ustedes